what are we doing here destiny too is
out on ps4 and Xbox one not yet on PC
that will come in October 24th but
luckily Activision and Bungie you were
courteous enough to send GameSpot a few
of the destiny to collector's edition we
are going to be unboxing one for you
here if you like these videos usually
Joey does these but he is out of town so
we're doing our best to fill in but you
know like it subscribe GameSpot if you
want some more of these and you can
check out all our others on our YouTube
channel and on GameSpot we're giving
some way too and we are giving several
ease away so follow us on Twitter if you
don't already we'll be putting those out
in the wild throughout the coming weeks
more details at the end of May let's get
to it
that seemed really close to my face I
probably shouldn't go toward my cheese
or yours I'd rather go toward yours
that's like the universe that's the
heading 101 I know oh oh you can see on
the back here everything that's included
quite a lot actually and judging by the
weight of it I don't know how to
accurately describe this but it's kind
of heavy I'd say like 30 pounds it's got
a good weight to it I don't really know
how much it would weigh you said it
doesn't too low they're pretty sleek
looking hunk of cardboard oh wait no
fallen out over that way okay Rob sound
effect one more time okay alright let's
break it down what are we looking at
let's start with this no wait okay let's
start with start with monolithic yeah
whatever that so according to the back
of the box here you see so somewhere
within this spire of plastic lies a USB
charger apparently solar powered which
sounds kind of cool Rob cue the sound
effects
okay so now you see we got numbers right
it kind of looks like front of the
Normandie
yeah so there are numbers here sorry my
fingerprints are getting all over this
thing
here at the solar panel I would assume
you can hold up both of them if they got
wings now maybe we could try this
outside it's San Francisco we don't
really get something let's fold those
back in now let's keep those nope
so I you here you see the power button
the solar I'm assuming you switched to
that diffuse and spot I don't know much
about solar panels but maybe that is
just I would assume like if it's spot is
more focused diffuses yes yeah all right
step backwards Oh what's what's this
stuff there's a dude this is wedged in
there's a solar blanket in here
somewhere
should we open it dude I could I can't
get that out this according to the back
of the box is paracord like a parachute
cord yeah you'll be using that a lot in
death this is a flying dutchman not it
spent a lot of time to Yacht Club's it's
tin foil that's a solar blanket Jake try
it on right now
yeah see how big it is
this is an operate on the mic yeah sorry
about the crackling this thing is oh my
god it doesn't stop we're just gonna set
this down for now on my head my mic is
probably very very peaking right now
this is totally warm and then I can tie
this around your neck while this is very
warm I'm not kidding is this is like a
real solar blanket I'm sweating I'm not
getting try this out try it out it it's
a very real heat gets trapped in there
it is worn it does get warm qualities do
that you've survivalists out there who
are like duh it's a solar blanket I
don't know
so yeah in keeping with the I would say
the survival kind of theme of destiny to
that blanket makes sense solar charger
USB charger makes sense secret
compartments I am surprised we found
those ahead and falling apart I may not
have found the solar blanket and
paracord when we wanted the next thing
now yes all save the game box before and
it also came with this nice little book
here except who's that on the front yeah
one of the Cabal red Legion I would
assume so yeah that's need to you can
kind of see that's a cabal without his
like Bane rebreather on very ugly but
it's a good-looking ornate kind of fake
book you could put some secret stuff if
you don't want your your parents or a
boyfriend or girlfriend to find I don't
know what that would be alright cracked
it open
get a little Goblet here nope okay nice
purple this is the shader I used a lot
and it doesn t want that blue 1 yellow
if it was both
do you know nope sweet poster some sort
of
schematic Oh sack is yeah dart
schematics for robots and mechanical
things wouldn't this be more of a
[Music]
biological blueprint if he will again
we're at very grotesque aliens next
thing we have we have small little art
book kind of wish it was a little little
bigger a little more to it but still
some cool designs in here here you have
a few like postcard
oh now stickers right postcard ish
coastguard right this is a sticker
there's a couple sticker you got some
old-school cabal like fable
there's also this holographic will I
don't know if it's being picked up on
the game there's also these little
things in here as well what are they
called cabal military pawns maybe like
some sort of things you use when you're
moving them around the map like a game
of Thrones they use those on the table
yeah town
well there's only a hole in one of them
it's not gonna fit well oh yeah you say
it doesn't fit I say I got a sick new
necklace see some some logos on there
for the Cabal the red Legion in destiny
to to plan out some attacks I would
assume if that is indeed what these are
I don't know what this one would be so
we will move on to the game though
something most people probably bought
this collection for or this addition yes
here's the game in its steelbook case
similar to the taken King steelbook that
we got last two years looks nice I like
the design of it pop it open of course
you've got the disc apparently that
doesn't always happen with these
collector's editions but the disc is in
fact here and then there's the digital
content pack and there's a 30-day trial
of course this comes with those two excu
yes Patrick one an tooth and a cold
heart exotic which you don't get two
you've completed the game fYI you get a
legendary sword as well make a ball
themed emblem and the legendary emo
correct in the premium digital content
pack okay there's still more though
right yes ah
this cord I assume for the charger yes
and then we pull this thing out all
right
what the bag is a busy looking bag
yesterday I feel like there's
instructions here looks like I'm sorry
if you didn't know this goes here
oh us putting a USB thing attach it
right there it because you know you'll
you need to make sure it's new to make
sure you take your solar blanket your
parachute cord and oh I'm wait how do
you end your solar power charging thing
imagine getting on the 38 bus wearing
this I mean it's kind of cool-looking it
fits your style
I wouldn't necessarily go for it is
there anything inside the bag do the
owners they're a lot of zippers a lot of
snaps kind of like in the frontier
driving dead zone from a bag
introductions for the howdy instruction
I how to use it I have no idea anything
else cool so I don't know the whole
package coming here kind of see I'll
hang it up for you it's not button over
the shoulder bag not curiously enough
it's actual backpack with two straps
which I found out oh right now oh that's
what this is for this is the over to it
so the instructions are form I'll show
you how to do it Oh gotcha
so you can do it both ways oh I know
what you're thinking
can you two be a proponent for a modern
survivalist Couture like Jake here yes
you can because the destiny to collect
position is available at Game Stop on
ps4 unfortunately not Xbox one but both
platforms are available on Amazon it is
$250 total to $49.99 we also here at
GameSpot will be giving away four of
these through our Twitter channel you
can follow us there you can retweet us
when we announce those giveaways as
always stay tuned to game spot for
future unboxings when Joey gets back in
town I'm sure he'll have some cool stuff
to unravel for you we'll see you then
[Music]
hold on hold on hold on you forgot
[Music]